shopify decides to team up with walmart
and their stock climbed to an all-time
high
after they launched a partnership with
walmart it's new membership
see how the e-commerce company builds
tools to help retailers while working
with e-commerce giants black's team
specifically focused on building
products
that support brick-and-mortar support
brick-and-mortar's retailers
with often complicated omni-channel
sales process so they can continue to
grow and compete with retail giants that
being said
shopify part of walmart in june to bring
1200 small and medium-sized shopify
merchants onto walmart marketplace
the new partnership will enable shopify
merchants to apply to sell their
products
directly on walmart's website hence
competing against
amazon reaching the site 120 million
monthly customers can you imagine 120
million people monthly
visit walmart.com this will help smaller
merchants get more exposure but it's
certainly a benefit to walmart as well
the partnership recently helped push
shopify
stock to an all-time high after walmart
announced walmart plus
its new membership service thoughts on
this partnership between shopify and
walmart
um way above my pay grade but i will say
this the market's usually really smart
about these kinds of things
so the market obviously thinks this is
great for shopify
and that was reflected in their stock
going up as a result of this
walmart's obviously a huge partner
they've got their reputation as being a
tough partner i mean they
bust the balls for years for years i
mean you know you you decide to get in
bed with walmart you you're selling your
soul to
you know they're gonna they're gonna
decide how much money you get to make
and all that stuff but
shopify is here to stay i mean shopify
is the real deal
uh at least i don't sell merchandise
online so i'm not a customer of it but
everybody that uses it
very easy to deal with by the way yeah
that's what i hear and so
the market's usually pretty smart about
these kinds of things they've evaluated
it
all the analysts have looked at it and
people don't just buy and discriminate
the market is usually right
so i'm going to say this is probably
good for shopify adam at this point
who wins more here does walmart win one
more here or does shopify win more here
i think shopify definitely wins more
than walmart yeah i mean i think that
just happens but i think
i mean at this point you got amazon you
got walmart
you got amazon you got walmart clearly
right now
amazon at least in the e-commerce space
is winning and walmart's just trying to
get in the game
i mean i i want to say get in the game
yeah try to level up their game in the
e-commerce space and shopify has
obviously
set the precedent that they know what
the hell they're doing when it comes to
e-commerce and walmart
is would you agree lagging behind amazon
when it comes to e-commerce
and they're just uh they're adapting i
mean it's it's walmart
versus amazon those are the two big boys
in the room let's see what
let me let me ask you this how many
products does walmart sell on their site
why don't you kai once you look up how
many products amazon sells on their site
how many products does walmart sell on
their
site i'm doing walmart you look up
amazon i got the walmart numbers i don't
know if you
okay i actually got both of them okay so
walmart.com sells
4.4 million products on their site
that's as of 2015 so that's a wild bag
out of which most products are not sold
at walmart itself
if you drill down further as of april 17
walmart
has a total of 23.5 million products on
sale so now they went from 4.7 million
in 2015 4.4 million
to now 23.5 million products on sale
while amazon you know how many products
amazon sells on their site it's 12
million
nobody amazon sells 350
million products on their site what yeah
so amazon
only sells 12 million but then there's
the the marketplace
which is third party sellers yeah that's
what they're trying that's the majority
150 million
products versus 23 million
15 times more products they sell than
amazon
is that really the measure though the
number of products or is it the total
sales
well no the way you look at it is
distribution right so if amazon's
selling 332 million and 12 million is
their own product
what's that we got tim okay if amazon's
selling 332 million
products of which 12 million is their
own products that means
the other 320 million is you and i
deciding to sell a card or we're selling
whatever that we want to sell to
that just means the affiliates are
playing a big role on amazon so walmart
just wanted to bring in
affiliates through shopify to say listen
you bring your
20 million sellers and let them sell
whatever they want to sell on the
walmart website if we approve them
it's actually not it's very interesting
what amazon's already doing and it's
working so why not
any chance walmart can catch up and
start competing again
with amazon beating amazon is there a
chance uh small but yeah
sure they're pretty small they're pretty
i mean walmart's still a bigger company
massive they have more giant companies
so yeah is it possible yeah i mean
they do have a lot of legacy uh
thinking that they've had to overcome
they tried to get into online early
failed they got to try to get in again
early failed then they bought jet and
the jets does okay
if you bought anything on jet yeah it's
not bad it's interesting it's not amazon
but i
sometimes buy things on jet if amazon
doesn't have what i want and so this is
the word this is where the world is
going and amazon's already figured out
so
walmart's late to the party but i mean
walmart's nothing you you can't
you can't doubt what walmart's going to
be able to do whether they'll catch
amazon i don't know i think they're both
going to be big players for a long time
two and a half million employees
worldwide by the way have you ever
bought anything on walmart.com
yes many times kai says no he's the
important one he's 22.
you have many times absolutely have you
ever been did you just call byron not
important
no no what i'm saying is they want that
customer yeah yeah yeah is what i'm
saying
who have you ever i buy on amazon all
the time i've never bought on walmart
have you ever bought anything on walmart
you have yes how much money have you
spent on walmart versus how much money
you've spent on amazon
it's not even close i've spent more on
amazon so probably like ninety percent
amazon and ten percent ten percent
you've never eric how old are you i'm 29
29 22 22 40
22 and i have never
bought anything on walmart
but jennifer has bought on walmart god
knows
many many times but we should buy on
walmart about once every
month or two what do you buy on walmart
that you can't get on amazon sometimes
you just can't find it on amazon believe
it or not like what i've never not found
something sort of who knows you're
buying guns
no you don't buy guns um maybe some guns
gun cleaning solution possible
seriously i probably buy something i
mean when i
see when i go into walmart i almost
forget my password or whatever
but i do buy things probably five to six
times a year on walmart.com
and i probably buy things you know
five times a week on amazon between my
wife and i eighty percent amazon no it's
probably ninety five to
ninety five it's mostly amazon yeah oh
so you are ninety percent
oh yeah but it's not like i mean i've
been buying on walmart foreign
95 on amazon five percent on walmart
yeah
amazon's your go-to if they have it yeah
you click the button you're done you
know
by the way if you're watching this i'm
curious if you're watching this how many
of you
have bought things on walmart can you
put your split
on what percentage is amazon versus
walmart i'm curious do you ever go to
walmart.com and shop on walmart
have they ever is that something they've
marketed like i never see
like i've never seen them come out i can
just say 100 we're competing with amazon
come shop online at walmart.com like
download the walmart app we're just as
good as amazon i've never heard them say
that
i remember i think i bought some room
dividers you know they just happened to
have what i wanted they just did these
these those
things that fold out and yeah and they
had what i wanted the price was right
and
um they changed their policy when amazon
came out with prime and everything was
free two-day
uh walmart was behind on that and then
walmart kind of caught up and says okay
we'll do free two-day or whatever
is is this the thing that makes
walmart compete with amazon online is
this move with shopify
i think what it does is it expands the
skus
so that if you go to amazon if you go to
walmart you find whatever you want
the odds of finding what you want on
amazon are almost 98 if you if
it's for sale somewhere amazon's
probably got it walmart maybe wasn't
there if they had
one-tenth the number of skus when they
have all the skus by virtue of
letting small merchants sell products
that they may not have on their normal
menu
it makes it easier and it's going to
bring more people to walmart it's going
to help walmart it's going to help
shopify
they'll help them both 120 million a
month monthly visitors is no joke
you